Fox News propagandist Tucker Carlson is really
playing up this Fox News crisis at the border
story, of course, the crisis at the border
started three days after Joe Biden took office.
It's amazing how quickly he was able to start
a crisis at the border. And Fox News has really
been playing this up. And this is just a perfect
red meat issue for Tucker Carlson. And last night,
Tucker did a segment on his show arguing that
the country suddenly is too crowded and that
crowded countries are unhappy countries.
Let's take a listen to Tucker Carlson.
Has there ever been an administration
this reckless and destructive?
What's happening on the border tonight will change
this country forever, a lot of things won't,
this will. And you should know that unlike other
disasters, mass illegal immigration is permanent.
No one ever really gets sent home. Over the past
30 years, the population of the United States has
exploded by nearly 100 hundred million people,
mostly due to immigration. Were you even aware
that that happened? You're not supposed to say
a word about it, as every year the United States
gets steadily more jammed with people and at
the same time more chaotic and less cohesive
as the open spaces shrink, as nature itself
recedes in the face of yet another strip mall
or apartment complex or fast food
outlet to serve the new people.
This is becoming a crowded country
and crowded countries are ugly,
unhappy countries. Why are we letting that happen?
So there are about five layers of things to talk
about here. And I really hope that these
segments are instructive for I think these
are great because we start with just like a
cartoonish or wacky thing from right wing media,
which I think interests a lot of people. But
then we actually look at the data behind a lot
of these things and hopefully we come out with
a better understanding of how the world works.
First of all, is just the political posturing and
the hypocrisy. Why do this segment 55, what is it?
Fifty six days into Joe Biden's presidency, but
you never did it during Donald Trump's presidency,
given that if the issue is the country being
crowded during the time that Donald Trump was
in office, the US population increased by six
to seven million people. And Tucker said nothing
about the country being too crowded. And yet
during Joe Biden's fifty something days in office,
during which the US population probably increased
by about 100000 people, all of a sudden now the
country is just stuffed full of people. It's too
crowded. The answer as to why he didn't do it then
and he's doing it now is because he only cares
about this issue when a Democratic president.
That's very simple. No. Two, Tucker, often focuses
on what he considers the tragedy of cities,
which I guess he believes are sort of war zone
health scapes. But the truth is that the U.S.
is large cities surrounded by gigantic
areas with very few or almost no people
in many states. And in fact, if you actually rank
countries by overall population density, the U.S.,
I think this will shock many of you. The U.S.
is one hundred and forty fifth in the world
in population density. We are right behind
Mozambique and Venezuela and the Faroe Islands in
population density, but just ahead of Kyrgyzstan,
Latvia and Estonia in population density, yes, our
population density is lower than that of the Faroe
Islands. So it's also not crowded. Many cities
are, but people are choosing to live there. And
if it became too uncomfortable to live in those
cities, there's plenty of open space that people
can find. And if Tucker is looking for open space,
certainly there's plenty for him as well. Now,
then he gets the happiness in terms of happiness,
happiness. I have studied, in fact, my my master's
here we go. My master's not really dissertation,
but one of my, like, final master's papers was on
happiness correlations. And there is no evidence
that population density correlates with happiness.
However, a lot of economic factors do. And people
can be happy in cities or in suburbs or in rural
areas. But it really depends on having a job
economic stability, social connections, access to
health care, which is part of being able to sort
of determine what you want to do in life. And then
lastly, population growth in the United States
is really slow right now. The population grew at
the slowest rate in one hundred and twenty years,
between twenty nineteen and twenty twenty
just zero point three five percent.
So this is another fake scandal where Tucker
and Fox and Newsmax and others, they want you
to think that the immigration crisis suddenly
is so bad that the country is now crowded.
By no measure is the United States crowded.
But then here's the additional layer of irony.
The real population concern is not about,
oh, it's too crowded, there's no room,
the real population concern is not immigrants are
flooding. No, it's none of that. The population
concern is climate change and sustainability.
The most science based concern about, you know,
you can say world population or U.S. population
is energy consumption and resource depletion.
And that's the one that Tucker doesn't actually
care about yet. He at least doesn't talk about it.
And he ridicules climate science and he ridicules
those who are concerned about resource use in the
United States. And what was notably absent from
that rant, a fact free rant, a propagandistic rant
was the real concern about, listen, at a certain
point, what are we doing to the natural resources
of our planet? What are we doing in terms of
emissions? What are we doing in terms of all of
these other things? If the if the world population
continues increasing at the current pace? Now,
this ignores all sorts of population dynamics
and theories. You know, you've got Thomas
Thomas Malthus and there's all this different
literature about this that's out there. Certainly
it's beyond Tucker's segment. But the point
is, if you want to have a real conversation
about the impacts of an indefinitely increasing
population, it's a climate change conversation.
It's an environmentalism conversation.
It's a sustainability conversation.
You're not going to find that on Tucker's
show anytime soon. That I can assure you